NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Our company sold
$1.6 million.
Wow.
But wait!
There's more!
[laughs]
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Your deal is the rabid dog.
I really want to shoot it.
You're not open-minded.
You're really not.
When people come in
that are delusional --
I forbid you to say
what you're gonna say right now.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
Oh, that changes
the game.
NARRATOR: ...They' ready
to invest using their own money.
I'll lend you $200,000.
I've already had people
offer me $500,000.
I think you guys are heroes.
I think the product's a hero.
NARRATOR: And they're
willing to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
10% means nothing to me.
CUBAN: Well, if it means
nothing, don't take it.
You're making a lot of noise,
Mr. Cuban.
Why don't you make an offer?
CORCORAN: You've got exactly
what you wanted from Lori,
and you're gonna shop
the rest of the sharks?
You're dead to me.
Get out of here.
"You better sit there
and be still, or this
is really gonna hurt."
CUBAN: [laughs]
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went from
waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
I'm Lori Cheek,
and I live in New York City,
and I'm the founder
and C.E.O. of Cheek'd.
I'm from a very small town
in Kentucky.
And I've always been
a very creative person,
and then when it came time
to make a decision
about what I wanted to be,
I decided architecture
kind of made sense,
until I came up with a passion
that was way bigger.
I've seen the
cutest guys here.
I'm an architect no longer
building structures.
I'm now building relationships.
Mm, he is cute.
Say goodbye to being single
and scrolling online for dates.
Cheek'd is a clever new service
that puts a fun twist on dating.
My concept has been tested
and proven.
After decades on my own
relentless pursuit for love,
I've Cheek'd an attractive man,
and now we're engaged.
Hello, this is Lori
from Cheek'd.
I have given up everything
I have and know
to build this business.
Failure is not an option
for me.
However, I am dangerously close
to it.
The reality is,
I am out of money and resources
to continue building my dream,
so I desperately need
this investment from the sharks.
Hi. I'm Lori Cheek
from New York City.
I'm the founder and C.E.O.
of Cheek'd.
I'm here seeking an investment
of $100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in my company.
Cheek'd is online dating
in reverse.
Initial attraction
happens face-to-face,
while interaction
happens safely online.
I once watched my handsome
friend pick up a girl
by simply scribbling,
"Want to have dinner?"
On the back
of his business card.
He left with a date,
and I left with an idea.
Him handing her
that intriguing note
was the perfect
non-intrusive gesture,
but I didn't like the idea
of all that personal information
on the other side
of that business card.
So, let's say
I spot an intriguing stranger
on my morning commute.
I can simply
slip them a Cheek'd card.
On one side, that card says,
"You've been Cheek'd."
On the other side,
there's an ice-breaking
pickup line such as,
"Act natural.
We can get awkward later," or...
"I'm hitting on you."
[tink!]
[chuckles]
CHEEK: If they're interested
in learning more about me,
they can go
to the Cheek'd website
and type in the unique code
from the card to see my profile.
Neither party hands
any personal information
until you're both
ready to do so.
Whoo.
So, sharks...
[chuckles]
...if you want a piece
of the next generation
of online dating, invest in me,
and now you're all
gonna get Cheek'd.
These are kind of customized
for each of you.
Top one, Lori?
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thanks a lot.
You're very welcome.
Why, thank you.
[chuckles]
You've been Cheek'd.
GREINER:
Oh, this is cute.
Okeydoke.
HERJAVEC: That's cute.
And for you.
"I'd fill your jewelry box."
HERJAVEC:
"I saw you tech-ing me out."
[laughter]
So, the only customization
on the business card
is that code at the bottom.
The I.D. code varies
with each individual?
CHEEK: They're numbered
like a checkbook.
So, tell me
how that all works.
You go in
and create a simple profile.
Right.
There are
nine simple questions,
and, uh, you order
a deck of cards.
So you can order
a 50-card deck,
or you can customize
your own deck.
Do I pay for them?
Yes.
How much?
They're -- the cards are $20.
After your initial purchase
of $20 for the cards,
you -- you pay $9.95
to keep that code
activated to your profile.
$9.95 a month?
Yes.
Do I have to sign up
for a year?
And you can opt out
at any point.
Any point.
Yes.
Aren't most people
using online dating
'cause they're too shy
or uncomfortable about
approaching people?
I mean, if I have the
courage to go up to you
and give you a card,
don't I have the courage
to go up and talk to you?
These are all very good
questions, but imagine I'm in --
No. I'll tell -- I'll answer --
I'll answer that, right?
The answer is, "No."
Way back, um,
my single days --
my friends and I
used to throw parties.
And -- no lie -- we would get
business cards printed up
and it'd have the date,
location, the time,
and it was like an invite
to a party,
but the point was, it was easier
to talk to girls because --
See? but you still
got to go up to them
and talk to them.
but you don't talk, right?
You just say, "Hey," and
this way, you know you're
gonna see them at the party.
Although it's --
So, some weirdo comes up to you
and gives you a card --
You don't
have to use it.
No, but it's easier
because you're inviting them
to a party.
You're not going up and saying,
"Parents love me."
Well, yeah, or you're --
and you just walk away.
Which means I'm specifically
interested in you.
Oh, Lori, who cares
what we think?
Trust me --
What we give them --
Do you have people
that are online today?
What are your sales?
Yeah, how many subscribers
do you have?
Is this
an existing business?
These are all very good
questions. [chuckles]
O'LEARY: Are you gonna
answer them?
Absolutely.
It's very exciting.
So, how many
subscribers?
So, I launched my business
in may of 2010.
So far, I've reached customers
in 47 states in America
and 28 countries
internationally.
How many in total?
How many warm bodies?
4,500 active members.
So, these people actually
have profiles on the site, so...
Have they paid something?
No.
I have had 1,125 people
pay Cheek'd something.
So, Lori,
over the last three years...
So, let me ask
the question another way.
You've made
hundreds of dollars.
How are you living?
This is a very --
also a very good question. So...
[laughter]
I love how affirmative you are
with our questions.
Okay, so, I have made $56,000
in 3 1/2 years.
And you're still living
in New York City?
I worked as an architect for
Christian Dior for four years.
In the time I was there,
I had a pretty amazing wardrobe.
When I came up with this idea
five years ago,
I decided,
"This is such a great idea,
I've got to make it happen."
I moved out
of my West Village studio,
and I sold my entire
Christian Dior wardrobe on --
Wow.
Where are you living?
Sofas of all my friends.
How much money have you
put into it?
$120,000 of my own money.
Wow.
Three years have gone by.
Cheek'd is making no money
at all.
You know, my definition
of a hobby
is something that never
makes money after three years.
[chuckles]
You've lost your apartment.
You're starving.
You're not making any money.
And what else can you sell?
I've had a lot
of technology problems.
I'm here
asking for your help.
The reason it's not working
is because my website
has been broken
with the subscription model
since day one.
And to this day...
So, and you keep on going,
and you keep on spending money.
You're not doing yourself
any favors.
I just got it fixed.
After burning $120,000, you --
you fixed it 3 years later?
I'm gonna figure this out.
I will take this business
until it is a household name,
and this is gonna change
the population.
I mean that.
People will -- people need this.
Okay, I have a rule.
When people come in
that are delusional,
I have to say, "I'm out."
I'm out.
Maybe I was overambitious
by saying I'm gonna change
the population...
You think?
...But I do think that people
want to meet in the real world.
I'm here
with a working website.
I'm here with a mobile-phone app
that's ready to launch,
where you'll be able
to search who's nearby.
But, Lori, it's the same
business model.
Right.
After three years -- you know,
the definition of "insanity"
is doing the same thing,
expecting a different result.
Lori, I-I want to tell you
a story
that's very appropriate
for you.
It's gonna help you
immensely,
and you're gonna thank me
for it, okay?
It's a story
about a boy and his dog.
[laughs]
One day, the dog
went out into the forest
And got bitten by a raccoon
that had rabies.
And the dog
slowly went insane.
The father made the boy
take the dog behind the barn
and made the son
shoot the dog.
Your deal
is the rabid dog.
It's a very bad idea,
and I really want to shoot it.
If you won't let me,
I have to say I'm out.
I think you've missed the entire
point of online dating.
People like online dating
because of the anonymity
and because
they're really busy.
I just think that the entire
premise is flawed.
If I have the courage to go up
to a woman like you
and hand you the card, I have
the courage to ask you out.
I think it's
a flawed business premise.
I'm out.
It's a cute idea, but it hasn't
been working for you, and --
It hasn't been working because
my website's been broken.
My website is fixed.
You know, I just read on your
Facebook wall the other day,
"The biggest mistake
anyone can make
is to be afraid
to make mistakes."
I've made every mistake
I can possibly make,
and I will take this
to the next level...
It's --
...with a small financial boost.
I will.
You can't let fear stop you
from moving forward,
but I think, here,
sometimes you have to see
that something isn't working
and really open your eyes wide
and look at that and say,
"Maybe I need
to do something different."
For whatever reason,
it's not really working for you,
and I don't think
it was just the website.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Barbara, I know you invest
in people.
You know, uh, I can't fault you
for your obvious passion.
When I started
a flower business,
for two years,
I killed myself.
I totally believed in
a "Flower of the Week" club.
No one had it. I loved flowers.
I loved my customers.
I killed myself.
I worked 24 hours a day.
But you want to know
what I wasn't doing?
Listening to the universe
that was telling me
it wasn't working.
You got to move on,
because it's stopping you
from going to what
you're supposed to be.
That stupid flower business,
if I had hung on to it,
would have never let me
be a millionaire.
You're the right entrepreneur,
but this is the wrong business.
You got to move on.
That's a great story.
And that's exactly
what I was saying.
I say it better.
Just shoot it.
[chuckles]
You in, or you out,
Barbara?
I forgot to say, "I'm out."
painfully, I'm out.
Thank you all very much.
Good luck, Lori.
Wow.
She's not gonna give up.
That's the sad part.
I'm gonna change the world.
I'm not quitting this idea.
I believe in this
more than anything,
and I'm not gonna stop until
this becomes a household name.
NARRATOR:
Next up are two sisters
who came up
with an easier way
to accomplish
a dreaded childhood chore.
Aww.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Jennifer MacDonald,
and this is my sister
and business partner.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Hayley Carr.
Our company
is Zipit Bedding,
and today we're seeking
an investment of $75,000
for a 20% stake
in our business.
3 billion children
live on this Earth,
and none of them seem to know
how to make a bed,
much less want to.
HERJAVEC: [chuckles]
And, frankly,
aren't you tired of seeing
your kids' beds look like this?
Well...
We were.
So, we invented the next
must-have bedding solution
for parents and kids
that's gonna revolutionize
the bedding industry.
Introducing...
Ta-da!
Zipit Bedding!
The world's first hybrid
of a sleeping bag
and a conventional
bedding set.
Let's show you
how it works.
All right, sharks, this is
our family friend Ava,
and she's 6 years old.
Hi, Ava.
She just lost
a tooth.
Okay.
So, it's simple.
[chuckles]
You just...
...Zip the zipper
like that.
That connects the top comforter
to the fitted sheet,
so now
it's all one piece.
Your kids can't kick off
their covers.
When it's time
to wash your bedding,
you simply lift off the fitted
sheet part right here.
HERJAVEC: Oh.
Wash it in the washer as one,
and remake it as one.
The kids are loving
the zippered side pockets,
'cause you can store things
like baseball cards,
game controllers,
flashlights.
But my favorite part is that
if your child can zip a zipper,
he or she can now
make their own bed.
And it's fun, like a sleeping
bag, so they'll want to.
So, Ava, hop on out.
Good job. Ready?
She just zips it closed.
And voilà.
The bed's made.
Here. Up top.
You did great.
Okay. You're done.
Nice hops.
CORCORAN:
Nicely done.
Good job, Ava.
Yay.
So, stop making beds
the old way.
Yes.
With Zipit Bedding,
it's now fun, fast, and easy.
You just zip it.
That was
our golf swing.
Does it unzip
all the way around?
Can I --
I want to go look.
MACDONALD:
Yeah. Come on up.
CARR:
Please, come on.
I mean, I'm just curious,
because...
It unzips on both sides
so you can detach the top.
CARR: So...the zipper
stops at the end.
So -- Oh,
it goes all the way.
MACDONALD:
All the way down.
And it's actually
open at the foot.
Yeah,
this part's open.
And this isn't
our only version.
We actually have
two other versions
based on comments from moms
that love this product,
but they also said,
"Do you have any for a
hard-to-make bunk bed?"
So, we have this giant,
bulky piece right here
that would fit
underneath here.
So, you got the railing.
Why don't you get out the
bunk-bed version, as well?
MACDONALD: Yeah, that's
what I'm gonna do.
You don't want to have to jam
the comforter side into there.
It looks messy. Our --
our goal with this is
to always look neat.
And this is our
glow-in-the-dark version.
CUBAN:
I got to say, like,
I would sleep with my brother
when I was little.
This would have been perfect
for Dutch ovens.
Oh.
[laughs]
I would have had him locked in
with no way to escape.
Thank you.
GREINER: I'm gonna ask you
the natural question for me.
Oh, sure.
Ask us.
Is it patented?
It's patent pending.
Do you have any sales?
We do.
We've sold 1,000.
We did -- we wanted to test
the market, so we printed 1,000.
We sold out of them.
And where'd
you sell them?
We sold them
mostly online.
How did people online
find you?
Actually, we just used
social media, word of mouth.
We did a commercial.
We put together
about a three-minute commercial.
Very D.R.-Style,
black and white to color.
DRTV -- that's Direct-Response
Television Spot.
Right. Yes.
Let's stay on the numbers.
You did 1,000 units.
Uh-huh.
Sure.
What was your gross sales?
What was your net?
Uh...
Made $7,500 gross.
And then we had expenses,
so we actually took a loss.
But it was just to test
the market.
CUBAN:
What did you sell them for?
Um, we sold these
for $59.99 twin.
Okay.
And $69.99 full.
So, what's your cost
to make one?
We've now gotten it down to $24
and this is $20.
That's the best that your,
uh, quote was?
You know --
We're working
with a production designer...
If you --
if I may -- sorry.
Yeah, go ahead.
...Who has 20-plus years
in the kids-bedding industry.
He loves this product.
He's actually hooking us up
with this bedding distributor,
one of the biggest, and they
have interest in it right
now. but we want a shark.
What do they want
for that interest?
MACDONALD:
Yeah. Um...
We were licensing the
functionality to them, so...
What was
their offer?
O'LEARY: Yeah.
They were giving us 50,000
minimum for the -- for quantity.
They're gonna
buy that many?
MACDONALD: Yeah.
And then it was gonna be 4% for
national and 6% international.
Have they
given you a contract?
We had a term sheet
that we got there, too,
and then
we actually jumped out.
Why?
That's everyone's
dream.
We went to New York, and we
flew, and we met with them,
and -- and they wanted to pay
for our entire D.R. campaign,
so we were really honored,
and we worked with them,
and we brought in a
broker to handle the
final contractual phase.
When it came to do a contract,
and we said, "Listen,
"y-you're trying to put this on
the shelves in summer of 2014.
We think it needs to be here
for Christmas."
This was five months ago.
That license deal
is very close
to a very interesting
opportunity.
Mm-hmm.
And I think you could get it up
from 4% to 6%.
It is -- it's --
Remember, they were gonna invest
money into our D.R. campaign.
75 million
kids in America alone.
So, it wasn't just the 4%.
They were then --
You guys, a D.R. campaign,
I have to say -- big red flag.
You know,
9 out of 10 fail.
And, personally, to me,
this is not a DRTV campaign.
Yes.
Did you
like those people?
We just feel like they didn't
have the passion behind it
that we're, you know,
prepared to bring.
So, it was like leaving a kid
in the wrong babysitter's hands.
HERJAVEC: But, Hayley, they've
got all the distribution.
They've got
all the stores.
Yes.
They're gonna get you out
in the market.
They're taking
all the risk up front.
We're actually --
the thing is,
again, we really feel
with this product
that it should have been
on the shelves yesterday.
but it's not.
We're --
But we're so concerned
about being first to market.
They're gonna get you to market
faster than you are.
They've been doing this.
You cannot start
from zero
and create the market
faster than they can.
We felt like
we lost some control.
We feel that we can.
And, to be honest, this is
a long-term product to us.
We're trying to revolutionize
the bedding -- bedding industry.
O'LEARY: You're very passionate
about the product.
It's very clear.
And you may have something.
I'm a license guy.
I love licensing.
I'm the king of licensing.
I could have helped you there.
I think this could have gone
all the way to 7%,
which is about the maximum
you can do on a license.
Okay.
But I know you don't
want to go there.
You've said that three times
already.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'll tell you,
it's very, very interesting,
because one of
the biggest obstacles
that people
come to "Shark Tank" have
with a product like this
is distribution.
Yes.
You came here
with somebody
that was willing to take that
risk and get you to the market.
I think --
But we also want guidance, too,
and that's why we're here.
We're -- we're ready
to bring on an ace in our team.
But I think
you can negotiate the deal.
I don't think you guys
really want the guidance.
You have a plan in mind.
No, we absolutely do.
That potential --
You know, Hayley,
I think Mark's right.
I think you have a very clear
way that you want to do this,
so I'm not sure
I share that same path.
Okay.
I'm out.
I think you have
a couple of huge obstacles.
Okay.
This idea of an infomercial,
anything like that --
forget about it.
it's just not affordable.
right.
Also, you didn't like
the licensing deal
because you fell in love
with your product.
It's like falling madly in love
with your kid.
You're not trusting anybody
with it.
But there's a franticness
to your love
that makes me feel like
you have no idea
what path you should be taking.
Our clear path is to
create brand awareness
on a national level...
How are you going to do that?
It's all in-house.
...With our catchy commercial
and a jingle.
How are you gonna
pay for the commercial?
We're gonna pay for it with
the funds that we get today.
But without
a clear business plan,
I think you're gonna have
a heck of a time
getting anybody to buy in.
I'm out.
Thank you. Okay.
We're just -- we really think
the product speaks for itself.
Ye-- yes, we do
bring passion to it, but --
CUBAN: Guys, guys.
You're the type of entrepreneur
that says, "I'm open-minded.
"I'm gonna listen
to all your ideas,
and I'm gonna tell you
what they are."
Yes.
You know.
You're not open-minded.
You're -- you're really not.
What do you think
it's gonna be like
for us
to try to work together?
For that reason, I'm out.
Okay,
we have one shark left.
Lori.
My belief is that you focused
on the wrong angle.
I think that you
should try
to get your costs
as low as possible.
Okay.
Sure.
I think that you should try
to get it into retailers.
I don't think DRTV
and an expensive TV campaign
is the way to go.
We're willing to do that,
as well.
We're doing --
We would like to do both.
We would like
to do both.
I hope when you walk away
from here
that you will erase that
from your mind.
Sure.
Okay.
Because that will be
a waste of money.
Yep.
Was it a waste
for pillow pets?
CUBAN: Yeah,
but you're not them.
I -- you guys
aren't pillow pets.
You're not them.
It's a different product.
MACDONALD:
Or the snuggie.
It's a completely
different product.
CARR:
What about snuggie?
There's a different formula.
Same with snuggie,
you guys.
Sure.
That's a different formula.
It's a different product.
Hayley, you need to be
in Bed Bath & Beyond.
But -- yes.
You need to be
in a traditional retailer.
We agree, yes.
We think
it's both, though.
Um...
We don't -- we don't see
why we can't do both.
You guys, four times I explained
to you that a DRTV spot,
in my opinion,
is the wrong way to go.
Yes. yeah.
And no matter what,
you kept saying back to me,
"We want to do both."
Sure.
We d-- we definitely
believe in that, so we'll --
we'll take your advice,
but I think, you know,
that is the route
that we want to go.
[laughter]
So, you know what?
If that's the way
that you want to go, I'm out.
CUBAN: Good luck, guys.
Go get 'em.
I'll look for the commercial
on TV.
CARR: Thank you.
I'm still sticking
to that D.R. campaign.
Yeah, I agree.
We're gonna get
our commercial on TV.
Okay.
[chuckles]
Those are two partners that
are exactly like each other.
Yes, they are.
Oh, my God.
They're sisters.
So, one gets off
on a tangent.
The other one...
It was like a couple
of zebra finches in a cage.
What?!
CUBAN: Next.
A zebra finch?
Yeah.
It was just...
NARRATOR:
Next up is a couple
with an eco-friendly way
to clean up.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Irene,
and this is my husband, Noam.
We're from Los Angeles,
California.
Our company
is cm national,
and our newest item
is Bambooee,
which will revolutionize
the future of paper towels.
We're asking for $200,000
for 10% equity in our company.
This is Bambooee.
It's like a paper towel
but made out of bamboo.
It comes in a roll,
and it's perforated.
And it fits perfectly
on your paper-towel dispenser.
One roll of Bambooee
with 20 sheets
replaces up to 286 rolls
of paper towels!
No!
GREINER: Wow.
Because --
because they're reusable
and machine-washable
up to 100 times!
[laughs]
We created Bambooee
because we really wanted
To make a difference
in the planet
by offering people
an alternative to paper towels.
Let's do a comparison
over here.
Here I have
a regular paper towel.
And here
we have a Bambooee.
[laughter]
And like regular paper towels,
Bambooees are super absorbent.
Look.
They don't drip.
Bambooees are stronger
than paper towels.
[laughs]
Paper towels
just rip.
Oops.
Regular paper towels
don't work when they're wet.
Bambooees are the only towel
that will work while still damp.
They'll work in your kitchen,
your bathroom, your shower,
your stainless-steel
refrigerator, even your car.
They don't scratch.
And look.
[tile squeaks]
It's bone-dry.
[laughter]
And like
regular paper towels,
You can wash them in the sink,
you can wring them,
and you can reuse them.
Isn't that amazing?
Amazing!
Bambooee!
But wait!
There's more!
[laughs]
We've recently developed
a floor-scrubbing Bambooee
that's reusable,
as well.
Bambooee Sweeps is a Bambooee
but with scrubbing dots.
They fit perfectly
on your swiffer,
and the most amazing part
is they leave no chemical
residue on your floors,
unlike regular disposable
swiffer pads.
Wow!
Can we see it?
Of course!
GREINER: [chuckles]
Now, watch this. I'm gonna use
a little bit of crayon here.
So, we're gonna
make a big mess.
Now, watch carefully.
Now, you can use
any cleaner.
So, you can see how effective
those scrubbing dots are.
Now, watch.
What you will notice is that
it will scrub, it will clean,
and it will absorb
without scratching,
whether you have wood, tile,
linoleum, even stone.
And look --
it picks up everything.
Those dots are crazy!
GREINER: [laughs]
And when they get dirty,
you just toss them
in the washing machine.
They wash up to 100 times,
and they're bleachable, too.
Bambooee!
Our products are made from 100%
sustainably sourced bamboo,
and with every roll we sell,
we plant a tree.
Sharks, who's ready to clean up,
plant millions of trees,
and make tons
of sustainable money?!
O'LEARY: Wow!
Bambooee!
That was great.
Are you selling any Bambooees
right now?
Yes, we currently, uh,
have been selling it
for almost two years.
And? Sales?
Last year, we sold $122,000
with Bambooee.
This year, we are hitting
about $300,000.
So, what'd you --
Is Bambooee
actually bamboo cloth?
CORCORAN: It is.
IRENE: It's made
out of bamboo.
Which is not -- which is not
proprietary unique.
They make that today?
O'LEARY:
Yes, they do.
It's available commercially.
So, bamboo paper --
Well, they --
they make bamboo --
they make bamboo towels,
you know, to dry yourself.
And cloths.
And
they make cloths.
Yes.
The product is --
But is he right?
Are there rolls of bamboo cloth
out there currently available?
Not this --
not this exact kind of roll.
Can you explain that
to us?
It's -- it's not
the same kind of fiber.
We have a proprietary
manufacturing process.
But no patent, of course.
Yes?
And we have -- we have
a patent pending as
of -- as of right now.
When you came out,
you said you have a company.
Yes.
We are offering
our whole company.
Our whole company last year
sold $1.6 million.
Wow.
GREINER: Wow.
Oh, that changes
the game.
Wow.
Can we touch it?
Yes, absolutely.
Okay, let --
Tell us what else
the other company does.
We sell a variety
of cleaning cloths.
What was your profit
on that?
$900,000.
CORCORAN: Wow.
Good for you.
Wow.
You could take that money
and plant a lot of trees.
[laughter]
Why do you need
our money?
We think that if we partner up
with one of you,
okay, we can actually
take this to the next level.
You've made an assumption that
people are going to treat this
as a replacement for paper
towels. I don't buy it.
If you're make -- gonna
make an environmental claim...
I guess --
...what you should be saying is,
"It's degradable,
just like paper is."
But to -- to say you're gonna
wash this and reuse it
means your footprint
is very heavy,
because you're using
electricity.
You're actually
using detergent.
That's going into
the water supply.
I don't buy
that part of the argument.
HERJAVEC: No, I-I buy
the argument,
'cause in Europe, they don't use
a lot of paper towels.
I think people
feel guilty.
They use the reu--
the washable stuff in Europe.
Yeah.
I think that's true.
I want to show you
that Bambooees,
actually, when you launder them,
they become softer.
And they don't scratch.
I have found out from --
Do people use this
on their faces?
They use them on their --
We are working on a --
on a line for -- for cosmetics.
Thank you. Hmm.
I'll share hers.
NOAM: Okay.
Now, they become softer.
I have professional detailers
that use them.
It's actually
less stretchy...
They don't get --
Yes.
...than the original.
They get softer,
more absorbent.
They're softer.
They don't scratch a car.
May I see that roll,
Noam, please?
I want to see
what it looks like.
Of course, of course.
What is the price point of one
roll, compared to a paper towel?
So, that roll
is our feature item.
We have
many different skus,
but that roll sells
between $12.99 and $15
in retail and online.
And, Irene, if that was paper,
how much would it sell for?
Um, paper-towel rolls are
between $1.50 to $3.50 a roll.
Wow.
So, it's way more.
Unless you buy --
Yes.
and there's another --
Yes, but you can go through a
roll of paper towels in a blink.
In a wink.
Yeah.
That says it's equal
to 286 paper-towel rolls.
That's right.
NOAM: Let me -- let me
just say one thing, okay?
You are not buying
just a product.
You're buying
three things.
You're buying us,
okay?
We're the hardest-working team
in the industry.
We've been together
for 16 years.
O'LEARY: I believe you.
But I have to look
at the merits of the in--
Number two --
number two.
There's three things.
Number two, okay?
We have an innovative product
like nothing that you've seen
in the industry.
Look, you're a great salesman.
I'm -- I'm giving you --
There's a third one.
I'm giving you --
Let me --
What's number three?
Number three is this is not
the only product we have.
We're creating new ways
of using paper.
We're doing toilet paper.
Washable toilet paper?
Don't tell me it's washable
toilet paper.
GREINER: Now, wait.
That's not reusable.
No, of course not.
This is disposable.
Not reusable.
[laughter]
Disposable toilet paper,
of course.
O'LEARY: You are definitely
a great salesman.
I'm a salesman.
I feel the kindred spirit.
I rarely say that
on "Shark Tank."
You're very good.
I have to look at the investment
for me as an investor, okay?
I don't find it
very compelling for me
because I don't want to go
through the educational curve
to accelerate this product.
And the other way
for me to do this
would be to put debt
on your company,
and this 10% tip
you're offering me is just --
But you've accepted
from smaller companies.
You have the opportunity
by us being a bigger company --
All right, look. you know,
you're very compelling.
Here's an offer for you,
all right?
This is the only way
I would do it,
'cause 10%
means nothing to me.
I'll lend you $200,000.
I'll put an 8% interest rate on
it, which is very reasonable.
And you'll give me the 10%
for incentive for me to do it.
That's an offer.
Okay.
He's a loan shark, in short.
I'll lend you $200,000.
I'll put an 8% interest rate
on it, which is very reasonable.
And you'll give me the 10%
for incentive for me to do it.
That's an offer.
He's a loan shark, in short.
The thing is, 10% --
it means nothing to me --
nothing.
Well, if it means nothing,
don't take it.
You're making a lot of noise,
Mr. Cuban.
Why don't you make an offer?
You know, I'm listening,
like I always do.
NOAM: Well, that offer --
I-I appreciate the offer.
You know -- you know,
we would love you
to be together
with someone,
because we want you to be
in our commercials saying,
"I forbid you
to use paper towels!"
[laughter]
I think if you did that...
GREINER:
They had a plan.
We would love to have you.
Make it part of the deal.
Oh, my goodness.
That's good.
Let's see if any other sharks
are interested.
Robert, what are you doing?
Just listening.
CORCORAN:
Lori, I want to ask you.
Can this be sold on QVC
like crazy or not?
I feel
it has to be demonstrated.
I think it's a great
demonstrable item.
And I will tell you, Barb,
I love the two of them.
I think you guys are heroes.
I think the product's a hero.
And I love
that you came in saying,
"Because our mission
is so important to us
"about planting trees
and saving our world,
"that we're willing to give
you sharks
a portion
of our entire business."
So, I'm willing to make you
an offer.
I'm going to give you
the $200,000 at 10%.
Because I think
what you're doing is fair,
and I admire it,
and I'd like to be a part of it.
Say yes while you can.
Wow.
[chuckles]
Is there --
Lori, our answer is --
Well...
What's your response?
I know that the rest of you
have not had an opportunity
to give an offer.
Would you like
to -- to pitch in?
CORCORAN: Wait. You got exactly
what you wanted from Lori,
and you're gonna shop
the rest of the sharks?
I offered you guys
exactly what you asked for
because I believe in
your mission statement.
Our answer is yes.
Good going.
Whoo-hoo!
We're gonna plant
some trees.
Whoo-hoo!
Nice meeting you.
Let's save some trees.
Good job, Lori.
Thanks.
Bye.
It's a good thing.
Good guy.
Wow.
Yahoo!
[laughs]
Yes!
IRENE: Lori was
the best shark for us,
and we're really excited.
It's gonna be the biggest
product in "Shark Tank" history!
NARRATOR:
In Season Three, best friends
Dallas Robinson and Mike Buonomo
pitched
their flavor-changing lip balm,
Kisstixx, to the sharks.
[laughter]
That's so disgusting.
I'm willing to give you
the $200,000
for 40%.
ROBINSON: We would love
to accept your offer.
We'd love to work
with you.
NARRATOR: Let's see
what they're up to now.
A lot has changed
since our last update.
My founding partner, Mike,
recently got
a great job opportunity
and left the company.
We still meet,
but I handle all the day-to-day.
See what it looks like.
Looks pretty sweet,
doesn't it?
Mark recently bought us
the website domain "How to Kiss"
and told us to use it
as a branding tool,
where our demographic
will come and find
tips, tricks, techniques
all about kissing.
It's already being searched
on the internet,
and this will be one place
for them to get
all that information.
We're here in Nashville working
with artist Danielle Peck.
She has a song called
"Kiss Me Like You Miss Me"
that is perfect
for our site and our brand.
♪ Every time our lips meet ♪
♪ Kiss me like you miss me ♪
ROBINSON:
Danielle's agreed to become
an official contributor
on our site.
[camera shutter clicks]
That's great.
"Shark Tank" has made
a huge impact on my company.
We recently locked in
our biggest distribution deal
with Kroger,
and now we have
almost $2 million in sales.
"Shark Tank" is the real deal.
[smooches]
Ahh!
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank is a doctor
with a product to ease the sting
out of the dreaded shot.
Hi. I'm Dr. Amy Baxter
from Atlanta, Georgia,
and I'm the creator of Buzzy.
I'm asking for $500,000
in exchange for 5%
of my company.
Wow.
As a pediatrician, I was ready
to rock my son's shots.
I had numbing cream on
an hour in advance,
but when the needle-wielding
fiend came in,
she said, "You better sit there
and be still,
or this is really gonna hurt."
And it did.
And after that,
like 63% of children today,
he developed needle phobia,
a problem that can last
a lifetime.
Driving home from
an overnight emergency shift,
my steering wheel was vibrating
because my tires
were unbalanced,
and my hands got numb.
I burst into my house going,
"Vibration!
That's the answer!"
And with a buzzing
personal massager
on some frozen peas
on my kids' arms...
GREINER: [laughs]
...I could leave marks
on their hands,
and they felt nothing.
Hmm.
So, that's how Buzzy was born.
Can we try Buzzy out?
CORCORAN: Yeah. [chuckles]
BAXTER: Buzzy is
an award-winning medical device
that combines
cold and vibration.
Thank you.
Putting the two together,
you can instantly numb
needle pain,
and it's been proven
in multiple clinical trials.
Thank you.
[buzzes]
Amy,
how does it work?
So, if you're getting
a shot here...
Right.
...So, you put it on
and numb it
for 15, 30 seconds.
So why not -- why not --
And I will not feel
the needle?
Can't guarantee that.
As a matter of fact,
what I can tell you
is that it decreases pain
between 50% and 80%.
We're in about 1,200
hospitals and clinics now.
We actually have
two issued patents,
four applications
that are filed,
two international patents
that are in progress.
Amy,
even more than patents,
what's important to me
is sales.
Do you have sales
of this product today?
We launched in 2009,
and this year we are on target
for $1 million in sales.
Next year,
we project $2.5 million.
Wow.
We've sold $33,000 Buzzys.
How many
in the last 12 months?
13,000.
Are the reps
showing these around, then?
Like, when they go
to doctors' offices?
We -- we don't have any reps.
You're not even trying
to sell them?
Well, obviously,
I'm trying to,
but I'm --
I'm a full-time doctor.
I know it sounds weird.
Nobody is selling these.
People are coming to us.
You have employees?
I have 6 moms who work for me
between 20 and 30 hours a week.
On the $1 million
that you'll sell this year,
what will you make?
So, $660,000
is our gross profit,
and $270,000
is gonna be our net profit.
Our average margin is 70%.
Wow.
Your margin's huge.
The lowest-cost Buzzy
is $39.95 for the home version.
Where do you make it?
I started in China, 'cause
everyone said start in China,
and the first batch was great,
and then the next batch
was awful,
and I spent so much time
messing with them
that I said,
"Just send me my tool back."
Amy, was it cheaper when
you were making it in China?
You know,
it was initially,
but the prices in China
have risen so much.
My last negotiated piece price
at my U.S. facility
is exactly what my last
quoted price from China was.
That's good to hear.
Yeah, good for you.
O'LEARY:
You're asking me to pay you
27 times
next year's pre-tax earnings.
You see anything wrong
with that?
So, if you think about investing
in a consumer medical device,
say, for example,
an Ava the Elephant,
that might be something that
helps children take medicine --
Barbara invested $55,000,
and now there's $100,000
in sales.
I invested $55,000,
but by the time we brought it
to market,
I had invested $285,000.
It's a very, very
difficult space.
That's why I'm here, because
you've already done that work.
So, I bet you've got solutions
that are much less expensive
for you to work with.
I'm gonna
tell you something.
Sadly,
I've had the experience
of climbing a mountain
and spending much more money
than I envisioned --
and I imagine this product
is gonna be the same
to bring it
to the medical space,
which is where
it should be.
And so for those
very real concerns, I'm out.
O'LEARY:
I have two issues with it.
Number one is,
it's not clear
what your distribution strategy
is going to be
to make this
a big product.
But the one that's really
killing it for me
and why I got a flyswatter
on Buzzy
is your valuation.
You're asking me to pay
a multiple that's higher than
a large medical-supply company.
That doesn't
make sense to me.
I think what you're worth today
is $3 million.
You're asking for $10 million.
That's a huge delta.
And if I'm just looking
at other opportunities
to deploy
half a million dollars,
why would I overpay
that way?
I wouldn't.
HERJAVEC: Amy, why do you need
the $500,000?
I need the $500,000
to scale,
because if I am in
even one big-box chain,
they're gonna need
24,000 of them,
so I need to order extra
to meet that demand.
I need packaging.
I need a P.R. firm.
That's a canned answer.
No. Do you want to look
at the numbers? I mean --
No, I know what it costs,
but it's a canned answer
in terms of are you expecting
to be in a big-box retailer
for this?
Yes!
Then who's gonna manage
all that?
Well, I'm obviously gonna need
to build up the management team.
Yes.
I can hire a C.O.O.
It's a huge mistake
to go into big-box stores.
Enormous mistake.
Because
you have to educate people
so that they come in
to buy them.
Doctor, you don't have
to reinvent distribution
for a medical device.
You don't get it.
NARRATOR: One shark is out.
The remaining sharks
like the product,
but have an issue
with the valuation.
Doctor,
you don't get it.
CUBAN: That's why
your valuation's wrong,
because you're selling
to the wrong places,
and you fully
don't understand.
GREINER:
It's a clever idea.
I know you feel that this
is more for a personal device
that you would sell
in a drugstore,
but the easier path
of least resistance
would be to go
the doctor/hospital route.
I don't feel that the deal
is the right one for me,
and so I'm out.
Thank you.
HERJAVEC:
Mark, what are you gonna do?
Who else is in?
I'm still in, but I'm not happy
with the valuation.
I'll tell you
what I'm looking at.
I would do this deal
for $500,000 for 20%.
HERJAVEC:
Kevin, is that an offer?
Yes.
My offer is $500,000
for 20%.
I've already had people
offer me $500,000.
They're not me.
[chuckles]
Amy, Kevin is right.
His offer
is the right valuation
for where you are today.
For you to get to that next
step, it's executional.
He offered you $500,000
for 20%.
If he'll have me,
I'd be happy to go in
on that offer.
O'LEARY:
I'm happy with that.
I'll take his $250,000,
put it with mine,
but I'm not changing
the valuation.
You're not worth more
than 3 million bucks right now.
You're just not.
So, $250,000 from him,
$250,000 from me
for 20% of the business.
What do you think?
I think no.
I think that the valuation
of $5 million,
while we
may not be there today,
in two weeks,
I may have another contract
that brings my sales up.
Mark, are you in,
or are you out?
Look, you might very well
be able to get
to your $5 million, $10 million,
$20 million valuation.
The question is,
how long is this gonna take?
Now, you may think,
"I could just hire a C.O.O."
That is not
as easy as it sounds.
You've got
an enormous level
of execution risk
and timing risk
that I think you're not
taking into consideration.
I'm of the mind-set of the 500k,
just myself,
for 20%.
The same offer.
Different approach,
'cause I think
it's more about
getting to moms.
HERJAVEC: Amy, regardless
of what his offer is,
I think three people have given
you the same valuation.
How do you address that?
I-I still want to push back
on valuation.
There are multiple
medical-device companies
that come from where I am
and scale quickly.
I see the opportunity.
What I don't see is
the infrastructure
and company to do it.
You're nuts
not to weigh in
the expertise
that comes with those offers.
Just think about it,
because I fear
your arrogance
is gonna make you
walk out the door
because you think
you can do it yourself.
I am so grateful
for the offers
and for the consideration
and the time...
...But I am gonna stick
to my valuation.
I can't watch.
I'm gonna --
I'm sorry, but I am.
O'LEARY: Okay, well, then,
I've made a decision.
You're dead to me.
Get out of here.
Thank you.
Good luck, Amy.
I can say this --
Mark,
if you had gotten that deal,
she would have
made you crazy.